look
chill chill chill
this winter bone sisters helped to feed
those who are in poor conditions and who
don't even have a clothing to keep
theirself warm your small donation might
mean nothing to you but it can change
their life and help them survive the
winter this year okay this is crazy guys
who is just striving with Musa in the
car
and
just behind me there you can see some
girl just jumped in front of my car like
and she's like I want to die I don't
want to live anymore
looking for the police maybe they can
she just jumped in front of the car and
she's like
bro that's mad
well that is crazy you know yeah
probably because the fingers but she's
trying to like
she's trying to kill herself man that
was more conviction
oh this is flipping crazy man this shows
you the reality of like the people what
the hell they're going through I'm about
I'm recording because I'm shocked on
label I'm recording because I'm shocked
bro
well if you think about it she's heard
look look what they're going through
right look we're driving and bro I
thought he was a man first just jumped
in front of the car she's like I want to
die I want to die hold on like crying I
want to die I don't want to live anymore
what's going on what's wrong she's I
want to kill myself I'm done with life
she can't tell us why she's done though
she's saying stuff like this and whatnot
wait what's going on
just know foreign
[Music]
chill chill chill
please
I'm gonna kill myself you told us you
were going home
I don't really care that much wait but
hold up okay
your Airport's just listen to me it's
not just the apples it sounds like a
very small thing
if we could go and look for them but
like he's doing oh sorry sis hit me up
real quick we cared
but then you came here now you're
complaining that he doesn't care
nobody cares
your issue is either you don't care or
we don't care
yeah she's
she's
jumped in front of my car yeah
I'll go with them
just
um
so we saw there guys was subhanallah a
very very disturbing footage because to
us we was like what's going on why would
someone do such a silly thing I thought
it was maybe a prank or people just
being silly but when you see someone in
tears and looks distressed that causes
alarm bells for you why would she do
such a thing and as we open the window
and Musa tried to speak to her and say
look why did you jump in front of the
car like what's going on and she was
keep saying I don't want to live I've
had enough of life I just don't want to
live anymore
so we was thinking can't just drive off
you can't just leave it there somebody
who's in that situation vulnerable drunk
and God knows what could happen and
sadly a lot of these females take get
taken advantage of you know strange rape
is one of these things that's happened
sadly when women drinks so much that
they end up going home with someone they
don't even know who could potentially
kill them or you know do God knows what
so here was more something a bit more
serious where she wanted to take her
life
so we parked stop the car first it was
shocked we got the car we tried to speak
to her and as he was trying to speak to
her she tried to do the same thing again
with another car and we had to like
stop the card to turn that look this
person is you know trying to harm
yourself and we told her like who do you
live with like what's going on I live by
myself you know I'm just depressed I
don't want to be at home and well like
this is what's exactly what's happening
in the Westborn sisters this is exactly
thousands of people that attempted
suicide thousands men are under like men
usually end up killing their self more
than females females also the females
attempt suicide as much as they do with
men so the point that I'm trying to say
here is brown sisters that this is the
lifestyle that I used to live clubbing
partying like you would go into that
nightclub and if you saw
boss what might you say all of these
people are the most happiest people on
this Earth
but you had no idea
that when the music turns off and the
alcohol stops And when everybody goes
outside and they go back to reality and
they are the most depressed people why
do they love the weekends and hate
Mondays why I believe if there was no
drugs alcohol
we will be seen dead bodies around
around London just driving past casually
it's these things just temporarily
keeping them going so they can forget
their misery and sorrow
I never drunk alcohol I tried it but I
never attempted suicide I never thought
of it but the fact that she I wasn't
happy in that state before I started 13
years or 14 years ago to look at her and
she's in that state this is a lot of
people
and we ask Allah to help them Allah says
in the Quran and the reason why this has
happened in brothers and sisters
in the Quran
foreign
hearts are assured by the members of
Allah unquestionably without a doubt by
the remembrance of Allah do hard to find
peace we are programmed we are
programmed that we will never find
happiness except from Allah's
remembrance what does that mean not just
doing vicar remember Allah live in your
life your whole purpose of your life
your creation is his remembrance
everything that you do from staying away
from Haram to do in halal to praying
Salah to go in umrah to understanding
your purpose here to read in the Quran
you could only survive this jungle and
this place this chaos this place of
chaos only with Allah's book and him
remembering him unless you don't do that
there is many things that's going to
take over
and the soul food is the remembrance of
Allah we go to the gym different bicep
muscles to train biceps legs this this
exercise for that what is the exercise
for the heart for the soul
it's such the it's the remembrance of
his Lord It's praying
if you want to keep that fit that's what
you have to do
so we ask Allah to protect the sister we
call the police and the police came and
hopefully
took care of her and we don't know maybe
she might come across this video please
watch this video and please
look into Islam you will only find
happiness wallahi the only happiness
that you find is here and for those born
Muslims why you do not understand what
you have
Allah has gifted you with Islam and if
you do not take care of this gift gift
he will take it from you like it says in
the Quran and give it to someone who
really loves him and he loves him he
really loves him and he loves them
brothers and sisters as Rivers we live
that life we know we know how filthy it
is that's why we grab onto Islam with
our molative
Muslims
I'm talking to you guys born Muslims
understand the value of Islam understand
what you have
for some of the scholars in the past
said if the disbelievers knew
what this religion does for us in our in
our hearts in our peace that we have
having Allah knowing what is written for
us is going to reach us and what is not
really written for us not going to reach
us
the peace that we have in our hearts and
the purpose that we understand
they won't pick up arms to fight us for
it they will pick up Armstrong Fighters
for it that is how valuable it is once
you taste the sweeten of Iman sweetness
of Iman nothing in this world matters
and just as with his remembrance two
hearts find peace in this world in
Jannah it is by his face Allah that we
are going to see that we're gonna forget
all the things Allah gave us in Jannah
just to seek his face foreign